so I only have a little bit of time left
with you uh so uh you know
um violent night did very well uh when
do you think you're playing Santa again
I mean before the writers strike there
was you know maybe something that came
in we'll have to see where it fits if
they can resolve all these labor issues
if the studios would please go to the
table and and these labor issues we
could shoot all kinds of things I'd love
to give to the people but yes we are
we're in process good I would like to
see you play that role again
um you're also going to be one of the
few people that gets to play in both the
DC and Marvel sandbox yes which is
amazing it has to be really cool for you
um have you started recording anything
for Creature Commandos where are you in
that process yeah we recorded a bunch of
stuff and I mean not only do I get to
play the DC Universe I guess played like
the James Gunn DC Universe which is a
whole new exciting thing
um
I I didn't know what it was when it was
sent to me I met with James and he sort
of laid out a lot of stuff it's it's
really exciting he considers that some
of the best stuff he's ever written it's
hilarious uh and the character's great I
think you know I think he's been
announced that it's Frank and
Frankenstein and uh you know uh it's a
very colorful terrific character so yeah
we've started to shoot stuff it's uh I'm
not one to really break but during this
it is wildly funny stuff so yeah we're
we're shooting it's hilarious I can't
wait for people to see it the thing
about signing on for this project is
that James has said you're going to be
the people that sign on are going to be
doing the animation the video games the
live action it's everything and so what
was it like to sign on to something that
you might be doing this for the next
eight to ten years well I talked to him
about that you know and there also is
this feeling of you're like well is this
the right one or what are you getting
yourself into blah blah and this
character's so good
uh I I wasn't really aware of this
character in The Creature Commandos
thing I wasn't even really aware of the
Creature Commandos and then I started
reading up on it and this character's so
rich and hilarious and like layered that
uh it was exciting it again it feels
like it's this new world where they
don't lock you in anymore like I feel
like Marvel learned that lesson as well
it's not like you know if you don't want
to do it I don't think they're going to
make you do 20 movies but I think it's
something where I just love these worlds
so much that it's a joy to do and a joy
to work with someone so creative so if
they want me to do eight to ten years of
this I feel like I I'll check my
schedule but I'll try to free up some
time